we are back with a new episode of the
wine down and today we are joined by
Kendrick Sampson who plays Nathan to
discuss Loki trying so Issa and Nathan
have a big heart to heart this episode
do you think Nathan still has lingering
feelings for you know he he also has
like guilt you know he went away for a
minute to figure this [ __ ] out and then
all of a sudden he's back and he's in an
intimate space with her it's
unreasonable of him to expect that she
wouldn't move on like the reaction to
hearing that she was back with warrants
was a mass ad no I think it's one of
those things especially things since he
thinks he has everything together where
you like I'm good you know whatever
happens happens you know and when it
actually comes face to face you're like
oh look you four yeah oh so you just
don't move on like that but it's also a
very dude thing to put him down gotta be
like but I'm better also
you got starting to kick it a little bit
so like in his mind it's like okay I
helped with the block party I called you
afterwards you came by my shop we kicked
it at the game night you don't know me
so it's like there's some hope there's
some hope that like oh maybe us kicking
it is like going somewhere so it's like
I'm doing this for you to reciprocate
but if you do I ain't gonna be mad you
know there's also like that it was like
drop a little things like well I did get
idea
[Laughter]
how does he stand Lisa's perception of
how he ghosted changed once she learns
the reason why is he's also bipolar yeah
I think that that puts so much in
perspective I think it goes from a
typical millennial Dainius of a man not
being able to use his words and then
coming back around all of a sudden it'd
be like we could write like oh he
actually had personal mental health
issues that he needed to deal with and
he needed to take the time to do that
and you you become more understanding
because you know we start off the season
in a very self-reflective way with you
for being like self-care Sunday and I
think in some ways that that might have
been a bit superficial in here is you
know someone who's dealing with so with
something where you actually know
self-care real self care is that
superficial I mean I'm self-care
suddenly like we actually do have to
take care of ourselves and sometimes
that's kind of the debate that I'm going
back and forth with like should she be
with him or not
you know what would I do in this
situation and all that kind of stuff is
just like people have mental health
issues and it's not you know necessarily
as scary as a lot of people think it is
there's a full spectrum of of mental
health issues but at the same time we
have to factor in our own health and how
we deal with people and just realize
it's just another thing you know sure
how do you approach and how does it feel
playing a black man with with mental
health issues I mean the way I see it
you can't grow up in America and be
black and not have some sort of health
problems and whether PTSD or something
so it was important for me to play this
it was important for me to have this as
a discussion a conversation starter and
also to amplify those those issues that
are important to me you know you and I
had conversations we had conversations
in the room about you know how do we
reveal this how do we do this or doesn't
feel like
as a thing and how do you honor it how
do we distinguish and how do we play it
as like this is one thing I'm dealing
with but it doesn't you know did like
define me you know and I mean and and I
believe we did a good job in terms of
how it comes out and how we talked about
it
at least something Paige and I believe
in the performances as well so it
doesn't feel like we're doing a bike
drop other thing that we're just saying
hey this is another thing that we need
to like make these you know it's an
issue but it's fine yes this giant
popcorn in that way and it's a part of
his life that he's dealing you'd like a
lot of us are you know thank you so much
again for joining us for another episode
of the wine down please join us next
week for the final episode of this
evening
you